hey Rob here with some Call of Duty
World War 2 beta gameplay you're looking
at a gameplay mashup of the new
objective base mode called war scene
from both German and American side if
you want to see more call Judy World War
2 coverage give us a like and subscribe
and as always thanks for watching our
mission is to destroy a battery of AAA
guns that's shooting down our bombers
but we have to push through enemy
territory and take out those guns before
crowd reinforcements arrive cache is a
command post to get intel on our
defenses our mission is to delay the
enemy until reinforcements arrive and
protect our flank that batteries will
keep enemy bombers out of the sky if end
the command post on the classified Intel
it hope - estimated post
[Music]
[Music]
come on
30-second clip posted under we capture
the command post the crowd Intel's going
to help win the war bill bridge to
replace the one the cross destroyed then
we can best stop the enemy from
rebuilding the bridge we destroyed
if they succeed their time for sense the
bridge is being built that bridge must
not be bi
they're building a safe spot in the
Brill Building research in advance
bridge in progress
eh
we built a bridge moving up yeah destroy
the German hammer supply so they won't
have units
destroy that
okay so she can race to space battery
we're
no one's UNESCO to us worried
Elmo seems to be near that pink thank
you sucking up
that's right
followed by no one nearby tasks for us
we couldn't get it done our
reinforcements arrived to protect the a
a guns